make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are once again setting our
sights on taking out the mightiest
beings in the universe
as our series on how to kill superheroes
focuses on one of the strongest
characters in dc
comics jon jones better known as martian
manhunter
so how to kill martian man hunter set
him on fire thanks for watching guys
peace now before we figure out how to
kill the martian manhunter we're going
to go over his origin and then take a
look at his powers to see why it's
actually
a lot harder to kill him than you
believe it is so martian manhunter was
first created and appeared in detective
comics number 225
in 1955. now as you probably guessed the
martian man hunter
hails from the planet of pluto no it's
not actually a planet but martian
manhunter hails from the planet mars
where he served as one of the planet's
law enforcement agents commonly known as
man hunters now one day jon is
transported to earth by a beam
built by a scientist named saul ertl who
dies a shock
immediately upon seeing him this was
unfortunate for jean as dr ertle was the
only one
capable of operating the beam and so
john was stuck on earth now on the plus
side
john's capable of shape-shifting and so
he disguises himself as a human and
adopts a human name which by a stroke of
incredible luck happened to be the exact
rhyme of his martian name so jon
begins a career as a detective and a
superhero and would go on to be a
founding member of the justice league of
america now his origin was rebooted when
dc
launched the new 52 so that jon jones
actually came to earth voluntarily to
learn how to be alone
which went against his martian nature as
the martians as a species were all
telepathically linked and so john needed
to learn this skill
so that he could lead the martians but
when he returned to his home planet he
founded a desolate wasteland with no
signs of life which led him to dedicate
his life to exacting revenge for his
fallen people now as far as his powers
go
martian manhunter is one of the
strongest characters in the dc universe
and according to the jla by grant
morrison is actually stronger than
superman his punches were able to harm
superboy prime one of the most powerful
versions of superman to ever exist
superboy prime was also able to alter
reality with his punches so the fact
that martian manhunter was able to
affect him
is pretty freaking impressive now he's
also able to fly at speeds
that allow him to keep up with superman
and the flash he also possesses insane
durability having taken punches from
some of dc's heaviest hitters
as well as a regenerative healing factor
that allows him to quickly recover from
whatever damage he sustains
and so it's probably out of the question
for us to overpower martian manhunter or
try to kill him through a purely
physical means since he can take an
insane amount of damage
almost certainly more than we'll be able
to dish out now in addition to his
superhuman physical characteristics
martian manhunter can also shapeshift in
whatever form he can imagine
and can alter the density of his body to
be either super dense
or intangible he's also among the
strongest telepaths in the dc universe
with the ability to read the mind of
every single person on earth
at the same time he's also able to shoot
powerful energy beams with immense
destructive power from his eyes
and so bearing all this in mind we can
see just how difficult killing the
martian man hunter
is because he's an incredibly powerful
character
but it's our job so how do we do it well
let's first address the answer
that's probably obvious to anyone
familiar with martian manhunter his
well-publicized weakness to fire
this has been a staple of the character
in some form or fashion
for most of his existence now this has
sometimes been depicted as vulnerability
or weakness to fire
and sometimes simply as a fear of fire
and sometimes he's only vulnerable to
fire that's magical in nature
his relationship with fire really just
varies depending on who's riding him
at the time and i think currently he's
suddenly just afraid of fire
because the entire martian race was
destroyed by it he isn't actually
vulnerable to it but i'm sure when you
clicked on this video the first thing
that crossed your mind was
just kill him with fire duh and i don't
blame you guys for thinking that because
it's the obvious answer
and it would definitely work because we
saw martian manhunter kill with fire in
the first issue of final crisis in 2008
he was literally just
set on fire and it was kind of funny not
overly funny but kind of funny
what was really funny was during tyler
babel where like they go to the forest
to try to find martian manhunter like
there's a great big huge forest fire and
he's just like running around
screaming on fire it was a little
comedic it wasn't supposed to be
but it was
[Laughter]
i mean i don't mean to say that i think
it's funny a person being on fire and
running around screaming that's not
funny but martian manhunter it was funny
uh he was also killed by superman's heat
vision in the injustice comics which
aren't really in continuity the
characters in that series seem to be
pretty much equivalent to their main
universe counterparts
albeit their powers and strength
fluctuate a little bit and so this would
also be a possible way to kill martian
manhunter if we chose to
and again referencing the tower of babel
batman's plan for martian manhunter was
to use fire so
if that's batman's plan we know it's
going to be pretty much foolproof but
for this video i want to go beyond the
obvious
and be a little less cliche so is there
anything other than fire
that we can use to our advantage well
it's commonly stated that fire is the
only weakness martian manhunter has and
that he's invulnerable otherwise
but is that true well the answer is no
there is one other substance to which
martian manhunter
has an acute weakness and although it's
not as well known as its weakness to
fire
it still produced devastating effects
and that substance is
tacos now if you're not familiar with
tacos they
are a chocolate sandwich cookie that
exists in the dc universe that are very
similar to
but legally distinct from oreos and
martian manhunter is addicted to them
literally they have an addictive effect
on martians in fact
he loves them so much that booster gold
and blue beetle played a prank on him by
buying up
all the tacos from all the stores in the
area and then just not giving him to him
but this prank backfires in a major way
as martian manhunter completely
flips out his shape-shifting goes out of
control and he starts destroying the
city
and the longer he went without chakos
the less intelligent he became
until he was eventually just a mindless
being destroying everything in his path
eventually he got some chocos and purged
his body of the addiction but it then
became a sentient being that he had to
destroy it's kind of crazy
but anyway how can we use this to kill
martian manhunter well i don't know
maybe we can just sit a mountain of
tacos in front of him and he'll eat so
many that his pancreas just shuts down i
mean do martians have pancreases
or maybe we just leave a trail of tacos
that leads him into a fire pit
and yeah that's technically using fire
to kill him so in a way
you probably didn't expect that when you
clicked on this video and that's what
i'm going for here to come up with a fun
and entertaining way to kill your
favorite superhero
that's the only thing i can really think
of right like just have a trail of tacos
and he's just like eating and then
following them and he's like oh
fire and he just burns alive and he dies
i'll be honest
i would read that story i think it'd be
amazing
right like like it's just it's just like
a one-off right dc showcase presents
tricking martian manhunter into like
burning himself alive
it'd be amazing with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end
if you have a better way to kill martian
manhunter post it down in the comments
section i would love to hear it
and yeah i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign